YUFENG GUO: With over 500
sessions at NEXT 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see Machine
Learning with Scikit-Learn
and XGBoost on Google
Cloud Platform,
then stay tuned because
here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I really enjoyed this
session because it
talks about using
Scikit-Learn and XGBoost
in some unexpected ways.
From trading in clusters for
large single-node virtual
machines to using
managed services to do
the scaling for you, this talk
was packed with demos, code,
and great tips and tricks.
Plus, you get to hear
from David Cournapeau,
the creator of Scikit-Learn.
What a treat.
Let's dive in.
Scikit-Learn and XGBoost
are great libraries.
And unlike TensorFlow,
they're not
used for deep learning but
for a class of problems which
are very common in businesses.
You may find that XGBoost
or Scikit-Learn can give you
better results with less effort.
We can view the machine learning
workflow through the simplified
lens of three stages--
preprocessing, training,
and prediction.
Preprocessing is a stage
of machine learning
in which the raw data is
made ready for the modeling.
This leads us to
training, which is
the process in
which the model is
tuned to predict a target
variable from labeled input
data.
And finally, prediction
is then that process
of predicting results
for new unlabeled input.
There are many challenges when
it comes to preprocessing,
and for unstructured
data, Scikit-Learn
can sometimes fall short.
Here, the machine learning
APIs can prove pretty helpful.
The full talk shows a
couple of examples of this,
and there's one in particular
where the Natural Language
API is used to
tokenize Japanese text.
And this solves a
problem that's not
suitable for Scikit-Learn's
preprocessing modules.
It's a really
interesting example.
The second stage of the
ML workflow is the train.
And if you know that icon, it's
the Google Compute Engine icon.
So you might be
thinking, are we really
going to talk about virtual
machines in a machine learning
talk.
The answer is a resounding yes.
Nowadays, virtual machines
have gotten way bigger.
Compute Engine allows you to
configure up machines with up
to four terabytes of
memory-- not disk--
memory.
And it's even got
the compute power
to pair with it so you can do
something with that memory.
And on the software
side, libraries like Dask
allow you to parallelize
your work in pandas
without needing
to have a cluster
of multiple machines set up.
Even at big companies, the
"large" datasets being used,
they end up typically being
less than 14 gigabytes.
And even for a truly
large data sets,
you can often just take
a subset of that data
for experimentation.
So don't underestimate the
cost of losing out on what
David calls "data agility."
The full talk offers
up a great resource
for helping you take advantage
of this kind of burst training
with a script that sets up
a machine, run your job,
and then cleans it
all up afterwards.
Definitely check
that out if you're
looking to try out
this mode of operating.
The final portion of the
talk covers Cloud ML Engine.
If your service relies on
predictions or if you regularly
need to retrain your
model on new data,
Cloud ML Engine can help
and Scikit-Learn and XGBoost
are also now supported in
addition to TensorFlow.
And it's for both
training and prediction.
So you don't need to
use different workflows
for different machine
learning libraries.
The full talk has a pretty
slick top-to-bottom demo
of preprocessing the data,
training a Scikit-Learn model,
and then exporting that model
and finally deploying it
to Cloud ML Engine,
all in one notebook.
If you'd like this video,
give it a thumbs up,
and I've included the
link to the full talk
in the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Google Cloud YouTube
channel for more great content.
I'll see you on
the next "Rewind."
[MUSIC PLAYING]